because what you've been doing here is
playing this game and we have all of
this like informal language here right
but in formal language only takes you so
far and so we want to develop like every
time you learn a new range of methods
you introduce the new terms a new
language so you can describe things in
more detail and more precisely okay so a
lot of these words will sound familiar
to you
which why I hope this infinity and if
not that's why we're reviewing them okay
so let's begin at the top here with what
we call an event or an outcome right so
you remember I said to you Audra is the
mathematics of unknown numbers and
probability is the mathematics of
uncertain events so Paul this means it
is something that can happen and you can
know whether it happened or whether it
didn't right
so for instance an event you would be
something like I've rolled a three
that's something you can know what
happened or it didn't it's an event it's
an outcome and when distinguish between
different kinds of events or outcomes so
for instance well I asked you rather
begin what's the probability of winning
okay now the minimum number of turns it
takes or demand a number of rolls of the
die it takes to win is five rolls right
I know Chris did a five roll win did
anyone else get a five roll win you also
got one two three four five or more go
that's all right
a win right that's pretty close it's
very good to winning the games is what
we would call a multi-stage event do you
see why because several things all need
to happen there are multiple stages and
that winning is made up of that event
it's made up of all of those other ones
or of course you could have won what I
mentioned before late rolling a 3 that's
a single event ok so there's nothing
else that affects that it's just like
done one one single thing ok so events
can be single or they could be
multistage
in addition they can be independent or
dependent right now does anyone remember
what these be can we come up with like
some synonyms or phrases that we made
the same thing we stopped at independent
what would it mean if I said two events
were independent
separates a Goodman what we doing used
yeah it's related to that let me we can
use all those words I'll stay with the
UM separate was the idea yeah so if you
got separate events right
it's like weighted money from a disco so
if I were all these two dice right they
both believe that's over helpful if I
roll the blue and blue okay
these are separate things right me
rolling this one and we wrote this one
they don't have any effect on each other
do you agree so therefore we would call
them independent events they don't have
any effect one or the other okay that's
fine
therefore if I have asked for example
what's the probability of getting kills
one day individual time right okay
oh what's the problem for your six
okay now every time you roll there's a
chance of gayness sees right he's the
chance independent each time or is it
dependent does the previous role affect
your chance of getting to cease the next
time it's independent right because
every time it's like well you know the
first time you roll and the 100th time
you roll presumably that the same kind
of wrong right
so the independence one in six sixteen
percent of issue every single time okay
as opposed to dependent in minutes right
so these are about does the past affect
the future so do you remember was there
anyone who got to a point me that I just
rescued one person all right I just need
to rescue one and then you keep on
rolling and it takes you forever to get
that last person did you notice that
right now just think about this right
this event rescuing the last person
understand person
risking the last person takes you
forever
compared to rescuing the first person do
you agree
like what's the chance of you rescuing
someone on the first term or just think
about it let's find out of six right
because it doesn't matter which of the
real so long as you don't roll a six
you'll rescue someone right whereas to
get the last person there's another
person do you see why that's a dependent
event shewest dependent it's because the
past what you've rolled before affects
it right so it's like I'm just waiting
for that three right that's the last one
I need and you keep on rolling ones and
twos and fours and you're like thatthis
is a pain because of what's happened in
past right so depending on the way you
describe an event that will make it
independent or dependent right let's
keep moving through we kept on saying
Anna six out of six out of six
this is what we refer to as sample space
can someone describe to you what sample
space is the size of the sample space
for a dice six the size of a simple
space that's um how many faces there are
right
so the definition of sample space is all
the events or outcomes that are possible
if it can happen it's in the sample
space okay so for example seven is not
in the sample space for any of these
nice okay because it's not possible it's
not part of the sample space and so six
is the only number of things you can
happen so the size of the sample space
is six the sample space itself is one
two three four five six
does that make sense so it might so
please no I wouldn't say the sample
space is six I'd say that the size of
the sample space to six that's how many
items there are in there it could be
like ABCDEF the size will still be the
same okay all right at last even though
it's like our heading now we're actually
ready to give a proper formal definition
for what probability is okay you would
say something like we use the Lenape
rather
probability every single time the
probability of something of rolling a
three time you know winning the game
okay any events you like so the way I
read this is the probability of event
and I can put anything into AI line
right is equal to the events that you
want we call them a favorable events
like rescuing someone the number favor
of it divided by the size of the sample
space right because that's how many
different things could happen so you
guys were all using that understanding
as we were talking even without the
formal definition because you're like
are favorable this for say getting
caught by Baltimore there's one of them
there's only one way to get caught by
Baltimore and what's the size of the
sample space well it's six there it is
what are your offenses so that fraction
is the one we're gonna use you over and
over again and it's when things like
this come from
right twenty-five percent seventy five
percent or a hundred right how would we
write each of these as fractions
what's 25 percent is a fractured that's
whatever fault very good and this would
be three or four I guess a hundred
percent which is percent mean again out
of 100 so 100 and 100 is just one one
and then you've got things like 5050
well that's 50 percent that's what's
shorthand for so 50 and 100 is of course
so you've got this spectrum from zero
all the way to 1 which means impossible
or certain and all the numbers in
between that make sense
okay so just lastly I will just quickly
draw a couple of these for you you don't
have to put too much detail here because
you've got something your text we're
gonna you're gonna join them yourself
tables and tree diagrams they're just
tools to visualize what's happening so
let me draw some point right just as
examples if I ask you to run roll the
dice just twice just twice
okay and all I'm interested in is do you
get caught by Baltimore or not right I
could draw a tree diagram like
this okay I could roll a six or I could
not roll a six now we've got a special
little symbol that means not I'll talk
about this symbol a bit more in a couple
lessons time next term actually this is
a fancy we have a fancy bow for this
it's called the compliment so this means
not six what's the probably of Ronnie at
six again can you tell me new it's one
out of six right so I would label that
part of the tree and that means the
probability over here is going to be
fine analytics right now one of the
things you'll notice is if you have a
look at all the branches possible and
you have a look at all the numbers I
mean we could have had like more
branches every one - you can see that
all of the branches have to add up to
one because they cover all of the things
that could happen does that make sense
so this is just one pair of branches
that's a bit boring
you can draw not six and you can keep on
going and to a point yeah in this
example this actually wouldn't exist
this one here because what happens when
you roll the six you're dead so the game
is over okay
so really this prize would just keep on
lying down this way but again you can
calculate the probabilities you told me
that it was independent every time so
it's still going to be 1/6 every time
you roll and this will still be five six
does that make sense which by the way
explains why it gets harder and harder
as you keep on rolling not sixes you're
going to get five six and five six and
all of these multiplied together because
you want all of the same time okay um
and you need a tree so if you have
actually get two nice speech if you roll
these two dice you can represent all the
different ways of all different
combinations of two dice in a table like
this you don't need to draw all of them
but you can simply do it like this
okay so sorry guys so you can have a
table one side represents one of the
dice one two three four five six and the
other side will represent the other die
five six and what you'll have is a grid
and you can your series in your textbook
sometimes they put dots here which is
why this kind of table is often quarter
does anyone know what it's got dots in
it it's called a dot diagram sometimes
even when there aren't dots there they
still sometimes call it a dot diagram
mister do mysterious each one of these
dots represents an event right for
example this one would be rolling a 1
and a 1 it's a pair of ones or this one
here would be rolling a 4 and then a 3
okay so these are just tools you can use